good morning believe nation today we're
going to talk about five ways to create
an incredible vision for your life as
you watch it there's something somebody
says it really resonates with you and
inspires you please leave it in the
comments below and put quotes around it
so other people can be inspired as well
Peter Drucker said that if you do not
have a vision to be a world leader when
you start your business on your kitchen
table you'll probably never be very
successful so if you're starting your
business on a kitchen table imagine you
could be a world leader and then you ask
the question well if I was the world
leader in my field how would I be
different from today how would my
company be different from today we were
just talking earlier about Steve Jobs
and Apple Computer Steve Jobs and Steve
Wozniak started out in a garage with an
idea to put together pieces and make a
little Apple Computer that people could
have at home Bill Gates of Microsoft
started off with this idea that if they
could make it usable you could have a PC
on every desktop it was her about that
that was his vision a PC on every
desktop in the world when he said this
in the late 70s everybody City must be
crazy
who the heads of the IBM were saying
there's no reason for anyone to have a
computer at home there's no reason for
anyone to have a personal computer and
within a couple of years they were
literally avalanched out of the business
because you find that everybody wanted a
personal computer the only question was
the technology to build it now the
programs to do operate today if you
don't have a computer you're living in
the stone Age's people your telephone is
a computer you have an iPad you have a
computer at home you have them so so we
just aren't thinking of if your business
was world class if you were world class
how would you be different from today
and then here's the key this is the key
take the first step the first step is
always the hardest step because it
forces you like a like a chick breaking
out of an egg when it hatches the first
step forces you to break out of your
comfort zone
and the comfort zone is so strong that
probably 90% of people are held back
from their full potential
all their lives because of this
vice-like comfort zone and when you take
the first step the only way you can do
is break out and suddenly you see the
second step and the third step and the
fourth step and then as you take the
stature self-esteem goes up and your
self-confidence goes up and you become
more creative and you start to think of
all kinds of ideas and people say what
has gotten into you I mean what are you
smoking because whatever it is you
should share it with the others and and
so this is the difference between top
people is they have a big idea of what's
possible and then take the first step
three things I want you to do to nurture
your vision I want you to affirm it
every day
affirmative a day and don't affirm it is
I'm trying I wish I want to I am let me
hear you say I am I am every single day
I am is the creative force of the
universe whatever you attach I am to you
will become you know people say I'm
broke
I'm single no I'm waiting for my ideal
mate to present himself to me in a way
that I recognize whatever you attach I
am - I'm confused no I am awaiting
clarity in this moment so affirm your
vision every day and just because
somebody else can't see your vision
doesn't mean that it's not a powerful
vision for you
here's another key for you never judge
your clarity on how other people respond
did you hear me they'll say what you
doing you crazy
why are you doing that you can't do that
who tell you you could do that who do
you think you are I love that one
who do you think you are me affirm your
vision clarify your vision know what
you're doing why you're doing it and how
you're doing it day by day moment by
moment and sometime the how only shows
up on a need-to-know basis don't wait
for the how until you start pursuing
your vision you understand don't wait
for the house sometimes you just have to
walk blindly but if you just do your
vision every single day putting one foot
in front of the other committed to your
desires being obedient walking through
your fears the vision will unfold much
grander than you could have ever even
imagined or asked for so this is what I
say to support your vision instead of
begging for it pleading for it pray oh
god please open your please come please
will God please please God
whoa hallelu halleluya be still
let your daily spiritual practice be one
a stillness and listening listen for the
instruction instead of begging for the
direction listen be still if you want to
do a dream collage I'm going to show you
exactly what a dream collage looks like
a dream collage is basically you open up
your journal and you get a few free
pages okay and then you take all the
images of your ideal life or your dreams
coming true and this you glue them into
this in your journal so you get this
collage of all these perfect things that
you want to have happen now what's the
primary principle it's this the
subconscious mind runs about 95 percent
of your life
only 5% of your life or what you're
perceiving is is really it's 5% is your
conscious mind most of what's happening
in your life right now is being run by
the 95 percent that sort of the
invisible world which is your
subconscious mind and the real key is
the subconscious mind operates through
pictures so you want to use that to your
advantage and I've got for example I've
got Architectural Digest we're going to
rip out some pictures here I'll show you
exactly what I mean in a second we've
got the rod report so let's say a lot of
people they like nice cars I've got a
picture of a Fisker here I'm going to
show you you know big house a lot of
people want a big house so I'm going to
show you exactly how to do a dream
collage so you can get this done really
quickly so you start running pictures
through your subconscious mind and
believe it or not okay once you start
training your subconscious mind to focus
on both the visual life's that you want
then your performance starts to follow
because your performance is always
aligned with yourself
mine again only 5% is run by your
conscious mind so I want to show you the
dream collage in action you know I took
a travel and leisure and what I did was
I took it a picture of the Eiffel Tower
let's say the Eiffel Tower is one of
your places to visit you know you've got
your journal and you've actually got
your magnificent obsession statement you
glue it into your journal on one page
and then let's say you're into yachts so
I got this from a rib got another
magazine from another magazine the rod
report so if you're into yachts let's
say I mean dream big right um you put
your your picture of your yacht in here
then I took another magazine
Architectural Digest a lot of people
have big homes it's a you know
meaningful goal to a lot of people and I
took out a picture of just a beautiful
modern home you know you can you can
have a look at it right there and that
goes into your dream collage literally
you pasted the pictures of your ideal
life maybe it's your fitness level maybe
it's the car you want to drive
everything goes into this dream collage
you look at it every morning when you
get up you look at it every evening when
before you go to sleep and really what
it's all about is this ever since we've
been little kids we've picked up all
these mess all of this messaging from
our parents from our teachers from our
peers from society and that literally
forms that ninety five percent that
we're not conscious of so that five
percent is what we're conscious of but
it's the ninety five subconscious part
of our brains that is really running the
show and we have all of these fears and
all these doubts and all these messages
that we've picked up about what we can't
do don't dream like this you could never
have this kind of car or you could never
run this kind of business or you can't
change the world and literally we go
through life and we wonder why we can't
make your dreams come true and we blame
it on the outer world and we play victim
but the reality is it's our own selves
we are our own saboteurs in so many ways
and this dream collage with a
magnificent obsession the first way that
I beat procrastination will really help
you shatter your chains so you get big
things done we have as humans we have
something that no animal has and what
his call is imagination and what
imagination allows you to do
allows you to see it before it actually
happened that's right I'm talking about
the greats like Albert Einstein e equals
MC squared that's right Einstein said he
saw it in his mind
long before it happened it was in his
mind's eye before it was physically
tangible and so the first thing I need
you to do for me is I need you to live
in the forward what do you mean by that
what I mean by that is I need you to go
ten years into the future twenty years
into the future
and I need you to see yourself actually
becoming the person you want to be and
you need to do me a favor I need 30
minutes a day
I need 30 solid minutes a day of you
actually sitting down I want you to
block their whole whole out put some
music on some classical music write the
piano a beauty I don't know what you
need to listen to but I want you to take
30 minutes go in the closet go in the
basement go go to the library go ahead
I'm going through a room alone and I
want you to take 30 minutes and I want
you to imagine I want you to take 30
minutes and I want you to live it afford
see the problem is I'm talking to some
of you guys the problem that you're
having is you're living in the future
and you live in the present and you keep
talking about the mistakes you keep
talking about the past you keep talking
about your trials you keep talking about
your situation and I want you to know
that everybody has ever been great
everybody has had an option to overcome
they've had a barrier that they had to
climb there is no individual who's every
success and he didn't have to go through
an obstacle or a barrier to get there so
do me a huge favor I need you to live in
the future I need you to go in your
future every single day I need you to go
in your future I need you to see what
you're going to be listen to me what you
are to be you're now becoming and so you
got to use your imagination and your
imagination has to take you behind the
pain your imagination has to take you
beyond the trouble your imagination has
to take you to the next level remember
what I said
nowhere in the world the success comes
before work but in the dictionary and I
want you to know that those people like
et that you see right now that's
successful it just didn't happen that's
right it didn't happen the first thing
we had to do we had to see ourselves
there
long before it happened vision is a
disclosure of an unseen reality vision
is a disclosure of an unseen reality I
know you all think it wait wait wait
shiny bald-headed black man that'll make
sense you said in unseen reality if you
how do you have a reality that's unseen
that doesn't make any sense it sounds
like an oxymoron like jumbo shrimp okay
good so that doesn't make any sense
how can you have an unseen reality y'all
it is the vision that connects what can
be to what is right there down the
vision connects what can be to what is
as the leader the influencer I want you
to understand this principle write this
down underneath where the head goes the
body follows where the head goes the
body follows so what I mean is this you
can't become negative because if you get
negative
they'll be negative if you stop
believing they'll stop believing if you
can't see the vision they won't see the
vision look folks I know right now it
looks like we don't have anything but
hey the vision is that this room is
going to be packed out I know that we
still have more empty seats right now
that we have if occupy full seats but
that's all right because the vision is
that we're going to be able to pack this
out and behave um we're going to have to
move to a bigger room see what you've
got to do is learn how to speak what is
not as though it were until it is you
are the keepers of the vision the vision
lies if nowhere else in your
organization is got to lie inside your
heart it's got to be the thing that you
are the most passionate thing about life
will pay whatever price you ask of it
you know what's interesting you got to
ask intelligently in the Bible it says
ask and you shall what yeah pretty good
formula you got to look into it
but you know what it's asking you shall
receive but I'm sure it meant ask
intelligently I'm sure that's what God
meant I'm sure he didn't mean [ __ ] and
you will receive wine and you will
receive I don't think that was the
instruction now if you're gonna ask
intelligently there might be five
elements of that number one you'd have
to ask specifically wouldn't you
wouldn't ask in a general way people do
the honest I want more money fine here's
a dollar get out of here very often
you're getting what you're asking for
you're just not aware of how general
you're asking clarity is power the more
clear you are about exactly what it is
you want the more your brain knows how
to get there
your brain is a servomechanism it's like
a bomb those bombs those missiles they
have a servomechanism so if the target
moves it knows what the target is it
follows it your brain when you condition
it knows exactly what to go for it will
find a way to get there keep it by a
certain outfit or a certain car and
suddenly see that car outfit everywhere
how many brab that experience say I how
come that car outfits everywhere it
always was everywhere but now you notice
it in reason because there's a part of
your brain called the reticular
activating system the RAS that part of
your brain determines what you notice
and what you don't notice your brain
spends most of its time trying to make
sure you don't notice because you'll go
crazy if you notice everything but when
you decide what's most important to you
your brain goes after it
everyone I know successful have builds
what I call an RPM plan and RPM is built
on the metaphor that the way to get from
where you are to where do you want to go
to the fastest is you got to build power
like in a car RPMs
and the R stands for they know the
result they're after they know what they
want precisely if you don't know exactly
what you want or you let yourself get
beyond that into something general
you're not going to achieve it clarity
is power you got to know the specific
result you after what do you want you
can't answer that question right now in
your personal life in your body in your
relationships and your finances and your
spirituality then you're not going to be
as fulfilled as you want to be today
we're going to have you answer one of
those questions at least the second part
of that you got to know P why you're
doing it because you know what you make
it a big goal suppose I want to make a
billion dollars I want to bring peace to
the earth why because soon as you come
over the goal all the obstacles show up
unless you've got enough emotional drive
to break through that you're never
discover what it really takes so you got
to get yourself past that and way to get
past that us have enough reasons reasons
come first answers come second this man
did not know what he wanted even not
have enough reasons to ask intelligently
you're going to have specifically to ask
intelligent you're going to know why you
want to have enough drive to make it
happen enough juice to make it happen if
you don't have enough reasons you will
not make it happen and the M is what is
your massive action plan what is going
to get you to actually fall through
because the first plan is not going to
work and the second one's going to work
so you better have enough plans that the
first two don't work you still got
something else otherwise you're going to
be having excuses why it didn't work so
asking intelligently requires that so if
we're going to be extraordinary in our
results we got them in an extraordinary
state we're going to know what we want
we got to go use it for me creating an
incredible future and vision is asking
two questions why and how the first is
the why because it's so important you
have to have a lot too many people don't
have a why and that's why their dreams
never happen you may say I want to be a
millionaire or I want to buy that car I
want to go travel the world but if you
don't have a really powerful why it's
never going to happen just having some
big goal that you think is aspirational
you want to shoot for is not enough you
have to have a deep and powerful and
strong why behind it if you look at the
people who've gone on and done great
things with their life created an
amazing vision and win and achieve that
they had a powerful why that even when
it was hard and they were slogging
through and it looked like there was no
hope they continued moving on because
they still had a powerful why to make
something better and then even when it
got easy even when they could have quit
even when they could have retired
because they had all the money in the
world or all the money that they needed
they kept going they kept pushing
because they had a strong why there why
wasn't addressed yet and so if you want
to do something great with your life you
need a powerful why to motivate and
inspire you the second question is the
how asking yourself how is an extremely
powerful question that most people don't
do enough up and as an example I was
talking to a colleague here at Toronto
dance salsa and it was proposing
something that we'd never done before a
brand new idea and all he was coming
back to me was with all the problems
what with it oh won't work because of
this because of this because of this
that's great
this
problems with anything I get that
there's problems you could poke holes in
the plan all day long and that's what
everybody else is going to do but if we
had to do this thing if this was our
goal then we had to go ahead and do this
with all these problems
how will we accomplish it and once you
start thinking about the how it puts
your brain on fire it aligns you in the
right direction because if you're
looking at whatever world that you want
to create whatever dreams scenario for
yourself the life that you want to live
if all you see are the obstacles that
are in your way that you don't have the
connections or you don't have the money
or you don't have the experience or your
country sucks or the government socks or
whatever it is all these obstacles that
are in your way preventing you from
getting to where you need to be if
that's how you see the world you're
never going to get there you could have
the greatest vision in the world but if
all you see is obstinate there or if you
start asking yourself how will I do it
then you start to align yourself down
the right path so having a strong Y and
then start asking how in my mind are the
two most important questions that you
can ask to get that vision for your life
to actually become reality for you so I
made this episode of believe life
because the unequal T V asked me to if
there's a topic you'd like me to cover
in the next edition of believe life
leaving the comments below and I'll see
what I can do I'd also love to know what
you thought in this episode what points
meant the most to you resonated the most
with you what change you're going to
make in your life for your business
after watching this video please leave
it down in the comments below I will
join in discussion I love this the
impact that it's having on you guys I
also want to give a quick shout out to
John Peters John thank you so much for
buying my book it really means a lot to
me those are you watching you want your
chance at a shout out in a future video
make sure to pick up a copy of the book
and email in your receipts who can keep
track thank you guys so much for
watching have an amazing day continue to
believe or whatever your one where it is
and I'll see you soon